scheißbahn ich komme direkt aus dem
Regionalexpress mit dem 49 € Ticket und
gefühlt 49 000 anderen Menschen die alle
Essen telefonieren und riechen Achtung
Witz was ist das einzig gute am 49 €
Ticket wenn du mit dem Fuffi zahlst hast
du 1 € für was sinnvolles
übrig gar nicht lustig ein neues Ticket
macht noch keine Verkehrswende es werden
ja nicht Züge es werden mehr Leute in
genauso vielen Zügen die Bahn muss nicht
voller werden sondern öfter und
pünktlich fahren aber das ist ja Science
Fiction ganz simpel erklärt hier passen
Zeh Eier rein mehr nicht wenn ich da
jetzt mehr
reinquetsche jetzt kapiert momentente in
der ersten Klasse ist noch Platz
frei